The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So
before class today,
you should have turned
in your vision statement
and your product backlogs.
Wednesday, you should be turning
in a copy of the sprint task
list, and you should
have a prototype
ready for testing in class.
Remember that while
we're offering you
one in-class testing
session for this project,
you need to do at least one more
testing session out of class
for the two focus tests that
are required for project three.
And when we look over
your focus test reports,
we're not going to be
impressed with focus tests that
were done so late you clearly
couldn't respond to them.
So the project is due Wednesday.
Don't do a focus
test on Tuesday,
because we know you couldn't do
anything with that information.
So sort of plan out when you
need a focus test accordingly.
So today is class,
we're going to open
with just a very
quick two minute
presentation from
each of the groups.
Since you've turned in
your product backlogs,
and hopefully you have
finalized your vision statement,
you can come and tell us,
what is the goal of the game
you're now going to make and
what its major features are.
That's all you need
to do for that.
Then we'll have a fairly brief
project management check-in.
We'll sit down,
I'll stand up here,
and we'll just do a
little bit of talking
about what is your team
doing for project management.
Is it working?
Should you change something?
Then Philip will be giving
the usability lecture.
And after that,
we'll take a break.
If anybody has something that
they would like play-tested,
after the break, we'll come
back and have an opportunity
for some play-testing
and working
on your projects in class.
If you don't have something
to play test, that's OK.
This is sort of a hey, if you
actually had your act together,
get a little extra
play-testing in.
Wednesday's the day you
have to have something
that can be play-tested.
Any questions?
All right, then.
Let's move on to presentations.
Actually up there?
Yay.
It is.
First up we have
Hardcore Dragon.
PRESENTER 1: OK, so I'm on
the team for Hardcore Dragon.
We've changed from Dragon's
Lair to Hardcore Dragon.
And the point of the
change in the name
is to reflect the slight change
in the direction of the game.
One of the new elements we've
added as a win condition
is collecting an entire
set of hardcore armor
to be the hardcore-est
dragon in the land.
And so we're intending
on adding a little bit
of a cheeky, funny,
dialogue flair
to the game to make it
a little less serious.
Outside of that, the
main concept of our game
is that you're a dragon,
and you have a horde of gold
that you are protecting
and also trying to grow.
So the player can make decisions
between attacking villagers
to gain more gold
and also staying
on their lair to be protected.
And we're also adding
elements of melee combat
so that the player is not
only making these decisions
cognitively but also
has to act on them
and actually go and perform
those actions, rather
than something that's,
like, just click,
oh, I want to do this
action, something like that.
So we're introducing elements
of strategy and melee combat
and also collectible
funness of RPGs.
And then elements
of our backlog--
we have the player's desire,
such as the playing wanting
to be able to attack, defend,
and also stay alive to fight,
despite the attacking armies.
And we also have a
lot of focus on making
our game usable and easy to
understand for the player.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
DNA.
PRESENTER 2: Hi.
So probably should have
written on the board
the project previously
known as DNA,
because we've completely
reskinned our game.
So it's no longer about
a biology type thing.
It's about exploring space.
So DNA is now the name
of your mothership,
And we're going to put you
as a small spaceship-- RINA,
so R-I-N-A, basically.
RNA.
And your goal is to travel
across different planets
and eventually make it
back to your mothership
before running out
of fuel or exploding
on a bunch of asteroids.
So our game has two
primary mechanics
that we're working on.
First is a menu-type
screen where
you can see different
planets that you
can head towards on your
way back to your mothership.
And each planet would tell you--
if you hover over each planet,
it will tell you, at this
planet you can pick up X fuel,
or you can get this
jet boost type thing.
And so the strategy comes from
the planning for which planet
to go to relative to
the other planets.
And the trade-offs also come
with which planet do you go to,
or what do you pick
up at each planet.
And the other mechanic is
actually getting to the planet.
So using a stat boost and/or
fuel that you picked up
from each planet, you have to
navigate through a platform,
or not really a platform.
More like Flappy Bird
or a Copter type level,
where your stats
increase, like how fast
you go through the level
or how maneuverable you are
and how you can avoid obstacles.
So our game has two
mechanics, and that's
what we're kind of
working on right now.
We have the moving from one
level to the next motion part
down, so now we're working
mainly on balancing the game
and seeing what should
the stat caps be,
or what should the
starting caps be,
so it's not too boring
at the beginning,
but it's also not too
hard at the very end.
And our backlog
has a lot of art.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Ghost Maze.
PRESENTER 3: So for Ghost
Maze, our design for the game
hasn't changed much.
We solidified our
original idea, is
that you're going to start off
in the middle of a dark maze
and you have very
limited visibility.
You're going to explore
the graph, or the maze,
and basically find the
exit that leads you out
of this dark scary place.
You have a sanity
bar that goes down
the more you are in the dark.
And you have the
ability to increase
the brightness of
your lantern, which
would give you a higher radius
of visibility or decrease it,
which would make it lower.
But the higher it
is, the less slowly
your sanity goes out, but the
faster that your battery dies.
So you want to
optimize for that--
how fast can I explore this
maze versus how slowly do
I need my sanity to drop.
And you can completely
have it off if you want,
because they're battery.
But that would be chipping away
from your sanity much faster.
There's ghosts in the
maze, so you can't just
do the bug around strategy,
which would always guarantee
you to get out of a maze.
But there's going to be ghosts
at strategic, random positions.
These ghosts were
originally intended
to have AI that would have
them find you or attack you
or whatever.
But we changed it
so that they're just
patrolling in a
predetermined pattern
so that you can focus on the
one mechanic of the game, which
is moving around and
finding a good path,
as opposed to escaping
from things chasing you.
The one change we made, the
biggest change we made so far
is we switched from
Flixel to Unity 2D
because we couldn't
get Flixel running
on most of the computers
we had, and it just
brought so many complications.
So we ended up
switching to Unity 2D.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Score High.
PRESENTER 4: So
Score High focused
on simplifying our game.
We realized we were probably
overextending ourselves
with the number of
features we wanted.
So even though our
goal stayed the same,
we kind of simplified
it, and I'll
talk about that in a minute.
So Score High's goal is to
survive the week of school.
If you can do well, even better.
And that becomes difficult
because as a player,
you have your stats to maintain.
You need sleep,
and you need food.
But you also need to
not fail your classes
and get kicked out, so
you need to do your work.
So the main features of the
game are you play your stats,
so how are you doing as
a person, your schedule,
which is going to list your
classes and what PSETs are due
and when they're due,
and then also the map.
You, as a character,
go around the map,
and you have to go to certain
buildings to do your work.
And as I said, the trade-offs
are managing you internally,
so you have to go to
your dorm to sleep,
but your PSET might
be due in two minutes,
and if you don't
run across campus,
will you be able to get it
done and pass your class?
In terms of updates, I
think that's about it.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Build a Space Car.
PRESENTER 5: So originally
we were Build a Car,
but we decided that the game
would be better in space,
so now it's Build a Space Car.
The idea is that you have
some kind of spaceship
that you need to
add components to,
and then you send
it out on a mission.
Out on this mission, it'll
run into random events,
and you'll get a report
of what happened.
And then it'll come
back and you need
to iterate, add more
components to either
make it faster or stronger
or have more attack.
And then that way, you'll be
able to succeed on missions.
The trade-offs come into
what components do you add,
and what effect does that have
on the stats of your spaceship,
and the fact that the
more components you
add to your spaceship,
the more it costs
and the less money
you're going to make
from going out on that mission.
The main product
backlog features
that we have are the things
like adding components to ships,
coming up with stats for
all of the components
that we have in the game,
and designing a system where
the ship will go
out on missions,
get some results
from all of that,
and then loop back into
this initial building phase.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
And MIT Sim.
PRESENTER 6: All right.
So the idea of our game is
we play as an unnamed dean
for student life at MIT.
And you make and manage
the decisions at MIT,
and you have to trade-off all
of these various resources
that you have, like student
happiness and the endowment
and whatnot.
And you have to please the
MIT president above you
and the MIT
corporation above them.
And then you also have to
please the parents of students
who might hear of some
crazy things happening
and you have to respond to them.
So for example, you might make
shoes mandatory on campus.
And suddenly East
Campus revolts.
But maybe it improves
your standing
with the parents or something.
So that's the general
gist for our game, yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So it's good to hear that people
are both refining and changing
and scoping down and
kind of figuring out what
they're doing with their games.
That's a good start.
The next thing I wanted to
talk about, ever so briefly,
is-- I've been reading
through the project write-ups
from the last project.
Haven't gotten all
the way through them.
None of us have.
We're still working through.
But a lot of people
are like, ugh,
project management got inserted
into the middle of the project,
and it was a really hard.
And it made things
clunky and more painful.
And yeah, I bet it
did, and I apologize.
What I'm wondering,
however, is what
are you doing for project
management on this project,
and is it working better So far?
I realize we're only
partway through,
but I'd kind of like to hear
about how has your team decided
to handle communication.
I know that meetings were
a big problem last time.
Is the product backlog being
a useful thing to sort of help
define your design?
Or are you doing it because
we're making you turn one in?
How are assigning tasks
and sharing work going?
So I can either do
this as a discussion,
or I can call teams one by one.
Do you guys have an opinion as
to how you'd like to run it,
or should I go ahead and
make an executive decision,
since I'm up here?
All right, I'll call
on people team by team,
and we can just
sort of go through.
I'll start with MIT Sim,
because you went last last time,
so I guess you can
go first this time.
You don't have to
come down here.
You can stay in the seats.
But OK.
OK, a microphone might help.
I wasn't trying to make
you do an extra report.
I was hoping this would be sort
of a class discussion where
you're--
PRESENTER 7: Well,
I'm already down here.
PROFESSOR: All right, go ahead.
PRESENTER 7: So I think one
interesting thing about project
management for our
team as 611 teams
is that the driving difficulties
of working on a team like here
are very different from what
might be in the industry.
So we have to adapt all
these industry methods, which
might work really well
for a game company, where
you have your eight
hours a day of working.
But here it's much
more sparse and not
necessarily-- it's
not always one to one
how you would manage an industry
project versus this project.
So I think just figuring out
how to adapt these methods
for students who are
really crunched for time
is a challenge.
PROFESSOR: Have you
made any adaptations?
Has your team made any
adaptations or changes,
or are you just trying to do
as little of it as possible
to help keep things moving?
PRESENTER 7: Probably
the latter, yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
If you can think about
the adaptations you're
making that are working for
your team and share them,
that would actually be really
helpful for us to hear,
and for actually
everyone to hear,
because I think
every team is running
into the same problems you are.
But the questions is,
how do you take these,
and how do you make it work
with a team you actually have
and a reality you're actually
working with, as opposed to,
this is the way
your should do it.
That's actually the really
important thing here
to try and figure out.
Thank you.
OK, Build a Space Car.
Do you have a
sacrificial victim?
Scrums masters
are a good person.
Yeah, it could be
a scrum master.
Could be either way.
PRESENTER 5: Our producer
slash scrum master is actually
out of town, so I
guess I'll handle it.
But basically coming
off of the last project,
we saw a lot of things
that we weren't happy about
and that we saw a lot
of problems with the way
that we communicated.
So this time we're
trying to make
sure to stay in communication
as much as possible,
let people know what
we've been working on
and the problems that we see.
PROFESSOR: What tools are you
using to stay in communication?
PRESENTER 5: So we're using
Trello for all of our tasks.
We have them there.
We have them color-coded for
different groups of coding
or UI or testing,
things like that.
And we have a Google Doc
that's sort of all of the ideas
that we had and sort of the
design decisions and things
like that.
We're also all
programmers, which
I think has been helpful
so far, in that we
sort of all understand
what goes into the task
and what's reasonable
and things like that.
Not to say that there isn't a
place for non-coding people,
just that it has
definitely helped on such
a time-constrained team.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
When you're all talking
the same language,
and you all come to the same
estimate assumptions quickly,
that's beautiful.
Thank you.
Score High.
PRESENTER 4: So I think one
thing we realized right away
was that meeting
outside of class
was pretty much impossible,
especially when you
have seven people with
completely different schedules.
So having the product backlog
and that list of things
was really helpful.
But at the same time, a lot of
the other project management
stuff is more just on the side.
So for my team, I've
been taking care of it
and trying to let
everybody else program.
But the product backlog, I
think, is really helpful.
And the vision statement,
having that breakdown
of who's doing what,
has been pretty useful.
We use an email thread, just
to keep everyone in contact.
PROFESSOR: All
right, Ghost Maze.
Two people can come down.
That's fine.
PRESENTER 8: Yeah.
So I guess as other
people were saying,
it's been hard to coordinate
meetings in person.
We tried to have one on
Saturday, but only half of us
could get together.
So definitely we have
to rely a little more
on online
communication and such.
And people are working
on different schedules.
So I think one thing we
realized is you have to budget
how much time people have at
certain points in the project.
So if someone has
a lot more time,
maybe they're more
free on the weekend,
then they could get started
on the earlier stuff,
whereas if someone has
a big project due today,
then we would give them more
stuff for later in the day.
Because when you
develop a game, you
can't do everything right away.
Some other things are
dependent on other things.
I've been taking the role of
scrum master, project manager.
So figuring out delegations
and responsibilities.
So I think it helps to have
one or two people plan that.
PROFESSOR: Thank you very much.
OK, and DNA.
In space.
PRESENTER 9: That actually
was the other working title.
It might become Finding DINA.
PROFESSOR: Pretty
much, whenever you
tack "In Space" to something,
it becomes infinitely better.
PRESENTER 9: I'll
do that now then.
So meetings are hard
because people have lives.
But we do little meetings where
we eat lunch with each other,
and only two or
three of us is there.
And the lunch is
tasty, and we talk
about cool stuff like
game design and weird bugs
and what exactly are we
doing with our lives?
As you may be able
to tell from the fact
that things have changed
drastically from the pitch
to now, we kind of basically
scrapped everything
at one point and
said, re-brainstorm.
Shoot out all of the ideas.
But of course, since we
already said the word DNA,
everything kind of ended
up DNA deep down inside
at heart, kind of sort of.
So I feel like we did a lot
of email communication then,
and we still do a lot of
email communication now.
It's just like, spew all of
the things at each other.
And I feel like,
that's kind of nice.
There are times when it's
like, well, I'm really, really,
really busy until Day
X, so until Day X,
I will have nothing to
say if we have a meeting.
And we're like,
OK, then I guess we
won't have a
meeting until Day X.
And it's like, well, Day X is
the day right before Monday
or something.
So was it really the best
idea to put that off,
or should we have
done it anyways
and have you just sit there
and feel lame about yourself?
I don't know, but
we did what we did.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And finally, Hardcore Dragon.
PRESENTER 10: So
looking up at that list,
the first thing on the
list is team communication.
And we actually have quite a
few different things in place.
We're using Trello,
so we do have that.
We're using a
Google Folder, which
is just shared between all of
us and all of the documents.
And we're also
using a chat, which
I assume every single one of us
just has open on our computer
and is just sitting there.
So everyone's looking in
on it once in a while,
people are commenting
on it once in a while.
That's how team
communication is going.
Design, I think, is probably
the most solid point
of all the things.
PRESENTER 1: Yeah.
I think we came up with pretty
solid ideas the last time
we met in person.
And since then, we haven't
really deviated from that.
It's been pretty straightforward
that this is our goal.
We might have to
cut-- we'll probably
have to cut features eventually,
but for now, it's pretty solid.
PRESENTER 10: I think we're
fine without cutting features.
I think it will actually fit
right in with the time we have.
I don't think we
can add features,
but we-- and I think I know
exactly what the game is
at this point.
And I think that everyone
else is in the same place,
but I don't know.
So I really think that
figuring out what our design is
is completely solid
at this point.
As for assigning
tasks, sharing work,
that stuff is sort of
a work in progress.
PRESENTER 1: So we
have a sprint task list
already that we've been
using to assign estimates
and people to certain things.
So far it's kind of
been a free-for-all.
But from looking at the task
list the last time I saw it,
it looks like
everyone's completing
things in a pretty good pace.
So I think that so far
it's worked out nicely.
PROFESSOR: OK, I
guess you're done.
OK, thank you.
I think that's everybody.
And now, Phillip.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So just a reminder that
this is project three,
digital prototype
two, user interface.
So in addition to all of
the project management stuff
that we've just covered
in the past half hour,
there's also the intent
to maximize usability.
And we've already talked
a little bit of usability
when Sarah gave the
last testing lecture.
Now we're going to do
a bit of a deep dive.
So this is going to
take a bit of time,
but I hope you will
follow me through this.
You're supposed to use user
feedback through user testing
on your own, which
means not just relying
on the testing that's
happening in class,
but also doing it outside.
So we're going to talk
a little bit about that.
Before that, I'm
going to walk you
through an exercise about
what's the intent of usability.
The whole point of
testing for usability
and designing for
usability is basically just
to figure out whether
someone can figure out
how to play your game.
Not so much whether they're
having any fun doing it,
although obviously
you don't want them
to be frustrated or confused.
But you actually are
just trying to figure out
whether people can understand
how to interact with your game.
The game could be improved
through play testing
to sort of say, oh,
the challenge level
might not be right for instance.
You can use focus testing
to be able to figure out
specific design issues in
your game, like for instance,
do these armor
upgrades make sense
to somebody who's not
on our design team?
Usability testing is
we have this thing
that we designed with the
intent of having it learnable.
And can people actually
learn how to play this game?
Now, just a straw
poll-- how many of use
speak or read German?
OK.
How many of you have seen
this game, or played this game
or have heard of this game?
All right.
So if you do speak
or read German,
just hold your
responses for a second.
And I'm going to start by
just looking at this game.
And this is a game that
you'll find on a shelf,
maybe in a speciality game
store or an Amazon shelf.
And just by looking
at this, what
can you intuit from what
this game is or who it's for
or how it might be played?
Any ideas?
Throw it out?
AUDIENCE: It's for
young-ish kids,
where they stack randomly-shaped
blocks on top of each other.
PROFESSOR: Wow.
How do you figure that?
AUDIENCE: Because it's
bright and colorful
and it has cutesy
cartoon stuff on it.
PROFESSOR: OK,
bright and colorful.
Cutesy color stuff.
AUDIENCE: The animals
are making funny motions,
implying that they are
precariously balanced.
Also, the alligator
isn't eating anyone.
PROFESSOR: The alligator
It is kind of
nonviolent, bright color.
What else on this
stuff here, assuming
that you don't speak German,
gives you any other clues.
I thought I saw a hand up.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The type.
PROFESSOR: The font.
The cartoonish-- yeah.
I think, Matt, you
had your hand up.
AUDIENCE: I was going to
say something, that there's
an exclamation point.
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah, yeah.
It's like, you can
imagine there's
something zany going on.
Anyone recognize the brand?
Has anyone heard of
this brand before?
No one has four-year-old
toddler relatives or anything?
Because it's a big kids brand.
OK, folks who do speak
German, what's on this box?
What's this box telling you?
AUDIENCE: The title
is Animals on Animals.
PROFESSOR: Animals on Animals.
So yeah, again, you're putting
animals on top of each other.
If you want to open
the box, and I've
actually gotten a
box, just one second.
You see these kinds of pieces,
brightly colored wooden pieces.
There is a crocodile.
But there's also this bright red
die with these symbols on them.
Any clues on how this game
is supposed to be played?
I mean, we already talked
about putting animals
on top of each other.
But here are the pieces.
If anybody actually
wants a closer look,
you can come in and have a look.
I'll go back to the previous
slide for you to see.
Any idea how this game
is supposed to be played?
Anything more specific than put
animals on top of each other?
AUDIENCE: I feel like you're
probably going to take turns,
and every turn, you're
going to roll the die
and do something
based on what it says.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And that's based on?
Making that assumption based on?
The fact that there
is a die and you've
probably played games
with dice before.
And actually, in the
previous picture,
I think it actually
says players--
is that a player number?
I guess it's off in a corner.
It is a multiplayer game.
And if you could
see that corner,
you would've assumed,
yeah, taking turns
seems like a normal thing.
That's based on
your own experience
of having played board games.
What else?
Any idea what these
symbols might be?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Based on
the hand symbol,
it seems like it
might be restricting
which hand you can use
to place the animal.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you are already assuming that
this is a very dexterous game.
It's going to require item
manipulation, a hand connected
to that.
There is a picture
of the crocodile.
There's a question mark.
I'm sort of walking you
through the process of somebody
actually looking at this
box for the first time.
And sometimes when you see
this kind of game in the store,
you don't even get a chance
to look inside the box.
But if you had a
display version,
you'd be trying to figure out
the game based on these things
that you're seeing.
Now, there is a newer
version of this box cover
that makes the stacking
animals on top of each other
really, really obvious.
That's the same cover
that I've got over here.
And this is the English
version, Animal Upon Animal.
But if you wanted to figure
out how to play a game
and you couldn't look inside
a box, what's the next thing
you do after seeing
it on the shelf?
You look at the back of the box.
And there, everything
that you've
intuited from just
looking at the components
and looking at the front of the
box is made even more explicit
at the back.
Now, it's in a tiny
little font, but you've
got a picture of two charming
kids who are stacking things.
Notice, they're stacking
everything in one plane.
There are some pieces
scattered around,
but the only things
that are being stacked
are stacked within this
single plane of the crocodile.
And of course, there
are indications
of how long the game
is supposed to be,
how many players it takes.
And of course, if you were
to actually buy the game,
you would look at a
manual, which happens
to have six languages in it.
And it would explain
things, like what
these icons on the die
are supposed to be.
But ideally you wouldn't
even get to this point.
And the kid is not
going to read this,
because I believe
this was targeted
at kids age four to 99.
So if you're age four, you're
not reading this manual.
A parent is going to
be reading this manual,
or some sort of older
sibling is having
to explain this to the kids.
So this isn't actually
targeted at the target audience
of this game.
Maybe it's targeted at
the buyer of the game,
but certainly not
at the people who
are going to have the most
difficulty playing this game
even though the game
is intended for them.
By the way, this
is a great game.
This is a whole lot of
fun to play with family.
So a lot of what I'm going
to discuss going forward
is just kind of a theoretical
analysis of that process
that we just went through.
We just used a whole
bunch of different cues,
just looking at the
box and the pieces,
and the text on the box and the
colors and cultural knowledge
to be able to figure out how
it is that you play this game.
Now, this is a game for kids.
It's not a very complex game.
If I gave you some sort
of really, really abstract
German board game, where
everything are cubes--
and there are many,
many games just
fitting that description--
you'd probably
have to read the
instructions just
to be able to figure out
how to play the game.
But ideally, you'd
want the experience
to be about as
easy as the process
that we just walked through
with this board game.
You look at this game, you're
presented with information
upon launching it or even before
you bought it, and by the time
you've actually started
playing the game,
you already have a sense of
what you're going to expect,
which sets people up to
learn the more complex things
that you need to teach
them along the way.
Now, there's a book-- which I
should have brought upfront.
This book I strongly
recommend, The Design
of Everyday Things, which
was previously titled
The Psychology of
Everyday Things,
because that's really
what this is all about.
Usability, designing for
usability and you are testing
usability, you are
asking questions
about the player's psychology.
And you are trying to use
that to your advantage
to be able to help them
understand how to manipulate
your game and how to get the
experience that you want out
of it without being confused.
Now, there's this model
that Donald Norman,
the author off this book,
goes into great detail.
And it says, there are
goals, there's an intention
that the person using an HCI,
a Human Computer Interaction
system.
And that person has
some sort of goal.
They are using
Excel because they
want to balance their budget
or something like that.
They have an intention.
They're going to put numbers
into the spreadsheet that
reflect their actual spending.
They have a plan,
which is they're
going to collect all
of their receipts
together and look at
those bottom lines
and start typing them in.
And then they
actually execute it.
They're actually--
all right, I think
this is the way how it works.
And then the computer
gives them some sort
of feedback-- visual,
audio, vibration,
if you're designing a game.
The person using the system
has to perceive it and then
figure out what that means.
OK, a dialog box
popped up on my screen.
I did something peculiar
and didn't expect that,
and then they have to evaluate,
did that get them any closer
to the goals that they had.
And maybe then the
goal changes to maybe
I should learn Excel before I
try to balance my spreadsheet.
And then now they have a
slightly different goal.
So you can translate
that into games.
You start off with the goal.
How do I win this game?
How do I lose this game?
How do I avoid losing, and
how do I win this game,
or at least complete it?
And then the player decides,
what do I want to do
and comes up with a
plan, which is how am I
going to do that thing that I
want to do, and then tries it.
The game reacts, gives some
sort of feedback-- audio, sound,
vibration, whatever--
but the player
still has to perceive it.
And this is a big
point right there.
If you give the player
feedback and the player
doesn't perceive that feedback
because they're too distracted
by something else, because
it's the wrong color
or it's off in the
corner of the screen
where the player isn't
looking, the player
doesn't get that feedback.
The player has to
perceive the feedback
and then figure out
what that means.
It's like, oh, a big
giant exclamation mark
appeared on the screen.
What does that mean?
I have no idea.
And even if a player
understands what that means,
they have to figure
out whether that's
getting them any closer or
further away from the goals.
So here's an example, back
to my StarCraft fandom.
You're playing StarCraft.
You wanted a giant army to
roll over your opponent.
And that's the goal.
Actually, the goal is just
to roll over your opponent.
And what do I want to do?
I want to build a giant army
to accomplish that goal.
How do I do that?
I'm going to build
lots of buildings
that is going to create
all of these army units.
And those army units are
going to serve that purpose
that I just described.
All right, let's try it.
Game reacts, and you get this.
What do I see or hear?
The computer is yelling at me,
saying not enough minerals.
What does that mean?
I guess I need minerals.
And is that what I want?
I guess.
If I have minerals, then
I can build those things
that will get me the army that
I want to roll over my opponent.
All right, my goal hasn't
changed at these long term,
but my short term goal has.
Now I have to figure out
how to get more minerals.
So in The Design
of Everyday Things,
Donald Norman introduces this
concept called affordances.
And the idea is that there are
certain kinds of interfaces,
things around in the world,
among the machines that you
use every day but
also within games,
that encourage you to interact
with them in a certain way.
If you see, for
instance, a glass wall,
and your goal is
to vandalize it,
what's the most natural thing
to do to that glass wall?
You smash it.
All right.
What if it was made
out of plywood,
and your goal is
to vandalize it?
You want to write on it.
What else can do
with a plywood wall?
Concrete wall?
You want to break it?
Or spraypaint-- yeah, yeah
because concrete holds
paint pretty well.
So there are these materials
that already suggest things
that you can do with them.
And you can take that concept
further in a more explicitly
designed way.
So let's look at door handles.
We've got some door
handles around here.
I guess there is this
kind of crash bar.
You've got this
sort of door handle,
and it's just the right
size for your hand.
It's kind of curled
in a pleasant way that
affords gripping, that affords
turning because there is
a hinge on one side, and
there's a sort of a lever action
so you can use less force to
be able to turn this thing.
So you are
immediately encouraged
to gripping this thing.
But what does this door handle
not tell you about the door?
It's very important if
you want to open the door.
Yeah, do you push or
do you pull this door?
So let's think of different
kinds of door handles.
This is something that
you could grab and pull.
But the designers of these
intended to use this for you
to push, because it's
a lot easier for you
to exert force going
outwards than to exert force
going inwards, using
this kind of bar.
That's why you see these on
doors that open outwards.
However, that's still a problem
because there's a little rod
all the way through,
and your hand
can go all the way around it.
And it's still tempting to just
grab the thing and pull it,
which is a really bad situation
if it's an outward turning
fire escape, for instance.
You don't want people
trying to pull a door open
when they should be pushing it
when they're in an emergency
situation.
You don't want to have them
do that kind of processing.
So that's why they came
up with these crash bards.
And eventually this one,
which is very similar to what
we have on our door.
They have these very wide
bars that you can push,
and you can put your hand
around it but not comfortably.
It's much easier for you to
use the flat of your hand
to be able to push it outwards.
And the version that we have
on this store over there,
the part that you push is off
to one side, which tells you
where you should be putting
your hands so that you can get
better leverage to open the
door-- which way the door
opens, left or right.
And that's the
kind of thing that
automates this
process of how do I
open this door in an
emergency situation.
These are affordances
of the design itself.
The material is mostly
metal, although I
guess the version that I've got
up here has a rubberized grip.
And the idea of
a rubberized grip
is that, well, maybe you want
to put your hand on the rubber
part, not on the metal part.
So you can design these
things in your games,
these affordances to
sort of encourage people
to, say, click on something.
You can design
something that's meant
to be clicked on to
look like a button,
for instance, that's
slightly raised.
And Apple does this a
lot, especially if you
look at the older iOS design.
Every single little icon kind
of had this little glossy bump.
It tried to give you
this impression that this
was something that
was raised off
the screen, even though of
course it was completely flat.
And it tried to encourage you
that this was a thing that you
can tap with your finger.
I'll go into more
examples of this later.
Anyone can think of
something that you've
seen in a computer
interface that encourages
you to use it in that way?
It could be mechanical.
It could be on screen.
Look at your
computers right now.
AUDIENCE: It's not like
this on Mac anymore,
but the scroll
baller has a little--
I don't know what you call it,
the lines that look like you
can grab them and scroll.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
it had a texture,
sort of three little lines
that sort of gave you
the idea that this was a
raised thing for gripping,
in the same way that a
rubberized grip over a door
handle encourages you
to put your hand on it.
It probably would make more
sense nowadays, actually,
given that so much of it
has gone to touch screens.
The scroll wheel
would be another one.
I just broke my mouse
scroll wheel this morning,
so it's on my mind.
Now, scroll wheels
on mice actually
do two different things.
You can click them, and
you can rotate them.
But they're kind of really
designed to be rotated.
And that's why I
broke my scroll wheel,
because I kept clicking it.
You are encouraged to roll
that thing up and down.
They're usually made out of
some sort of rubberized material
and a place right where
your finger has easy reach.
You can flip that around and
make things deliberately hard
when you don't want someone
to be doing something.
Here's a screenshot
of-- what game is this?
Plants vs. Zombies.
There are no zombies on
screen, but it's very popular.
And early in the game, early in
the development of this game,
they had different values
for these early items
that you'll get right
in the beginning.
This is I think the very first
level in the entire game,
and they're just trying to
get you to play this game.
Now, this is a
tower defense game.
You plant plants
that do various kinds
of offensive or
defensive attacks
against zombies who
are invading your lawn
and trying to get
into your house.
And there are things like
sunflowers that actually create
the energy that you
need to be able to power
the rest of your plants and
to give you the resources
to be able to put the
rest of your plants down.
But if the game
starts like this,
what is first a first time
player who's encountering
this game likely to do?
AUDIENCE: Put a
plant in the dirt.
PROFESSOR: Put a
Which plant?
AUDIENCE: A sunflower.
PROFESSOR: You think to
put a sunflower first?
AUDIENCE: Or the pea shooter.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The one on the left is--
PROFESSOR: The pea shooter.
AUDIENCE: Left to right.
PROFESSOR: Right.
If they read it
from left to right,
then they'll probably start
with the one on the left.
Maybe there's a
50/50 chance at least
that they will put
the pea shooter first,
which is the little green guy.
And that's actually
going to get the player
into a lot of trouble real
fast, because once they
put that plant down,
they can't do anything
for a really, really
long time, by which point
you may have lost the game.
They need to put the
sunflower down first.
So designers recognized,
oh OK, so we could just
flip things around.
But again, there's a 50%
chance that they will just
get it wrong.
At it's the first
level of the game.
You don't want to turn somebody
off the game that quickly.
So what they did
was they reduced
the cost of the sunflower
and started you off
with just enough money to
actually plant that sunflower.
They didn't actually
flip the cards around
because they figured,
that doesn't really
solve the problem.
What they did was
that they made it
so that the only
thing that you can
do at the beginning
of the game is
plant that sunflower,
because that's pretty much
always the right thing
to do in this game.
Now, the cost reduction
might have been also
out of other game
balance considerations.
Maybe they decided, wow,
we really overpriced
those sunflowers.
We should make them a little
bit easier for you to get.
But this also serves
a usability system.
They want the people
to understand,
the first thing that you
do on any level, plant
that sunflower.
Now, they could have told you
that, but this is a constraint.
They've made it
impossible for a player
to do the wrong thing right
at the beginning of the game.
However, as the
game goes on, this,
and due to game
balance issues, they
started to come up
with other plants.
This thing is called a walnut,
this brown thing over there.
It makes a wall.
It looks like a nut.
And they figured through
game balance, well,
it's pretty much got to
be about 50 solar energy,
so we're going to have to price
it the same as the sunflower.
But we don't want players
putting down walls
at the beginning of the game.
They don't actually need to.
They should still be
putting sunflowers.
So the solution
that they had was,
they have these recharge meters
that fill up from the bottom.
You can sort of see that this
is right at the beginning
of the game when you've got a
lot of different kind of plants
that you can plant.
But only the sunflower
is fully charged up,
and it's the only
card that you can use.
The rest of them are slowly
filling up over time.
Right in the first, maybe,
five seconds of the game,
there is no other card
that you can plant,
even though the costs
may imply that you
can afford to plant
the walnut right
at the beginning of the game.
You can't.
You have to plant the sunflower.
So again, they've
made it impossible
for you to do the wrong thing.
There's also that shovel, but
you can't use the shovel right
at the beginning of the game.
The shovel right at the
beginning of the game
has no effect because you
haven't planted anything.
So that's a constraint.
That's preventing someone
from doing the wrong thing.
Now, if the decision
of whether you
do the right thing
or wrong thing
is a major game play
issue and it's something
that you want people to sort
of agonize and to decide over,
then you don't want
to constrain it.
You want to give them the
option of making that mistake.
But if it's an issue
of learnability,
if making the wrong decision
makes your game hard to learn
and hard to figure out
how to even get ahead
and how to make
progress in the game,
or even understand
how your game works,
then that's something that you
should consider doing things
like constraints and use
affordances to sort of suggest,
this is what you should do,
constraints to demonstrate
what you shouldn't do.
Now, that's affordances
and constraints.
Any questions so far?
All right.
There are other things
that you can do in addition
to affordances and constraints
that sort of suggest
how something should be used.
So this is from Minecraft.
And how many of you
have played Minecraft?
OK, about a quarter
of the class.
This is something that you see
really early on in the game.
The way how Minecraft
is played, you
are dropped off in a sort
of wilderness environment.
Everything's made up of blocks.
So it's kind of like a
wilderness environment
made out of LEGOs.
And the only thing
that you can do
is walk around and punch things.
So you start punching the ground
and you get some dirt blocks
out of it.
You start punching
trees, and you
start getting some wood
blocks out of them,
and they go into your inventory.
What you very
quickly discover, I
would say, in the first
minute of game play,
is that if you went
into your inventory
and looked at those
blocks, you can move them
into this little four-by-four
square, just using your mouse
and clicking and dragging them.
And the square is
named crafting.
So OK, I've beat up 15 trees.
So now I've got
15 blocks of wood.
What do I do with them?
Well, if I drag them into the--
I can turn them into planks.
Is it planks?
Yeah, planks-- just by
dragging them up there.
OK.
By dragging things
into the crafting box,
I can make other
kinds of things.
That's the craft
part of Minecraft.
The mining part is the
punching part of the world.
So you punch the world,
and you make planks.
You put planks into the crafting
square, and you get sticks.
And you can do all
kinds of things,
like make torches and make
arrows and so on and so forth.
Later in the game, you
encounter something--
you discover that you can
make a crafting table.
And you see a nine-by-nine
square instead
of a four-by-four square.
Because you've already
seen the first one,
you've already seen this
four-by-four square, the word
crafting, and the arrow
which points to the right,
and now you're seeing this very,
very similar thing over here,
and inventory is
still visible there,
even though it's not
just you anymore, it's
you and this crafting
table, the implication
is that you should
interact with this table
pretty much in the same way that
you interact with objects back
when you were examining
your inventory.
So this is context that
has been established
to the previous things
that you're seeing.
And the things that
you see around it,
like the arrow and your
arrangement of the boxes.
And the word crafting-- you're
sort of telling the player,
treat this very
much in the same way
that you solved that
previous problem.
And then eventually
you get to make things
like pickaxes, for instance--
so giving some context to what
the players are doing.
Now, there's one particularly
powerful kind of context
that you can set for any action
that a player does in the game.
And some of your
games already have
this-- and that's some sort
of storyline or setting
or narrative, some sort
of fictional setting
that your game is
taking place in.
And often this is done
very, very poorly in games.
You are being told your
games are in space,
and you're being encouraged
to walk outside your spaceship
without a spacesuit or
something like that.
And in your game, that's fine.
You have no asphyxiation
mechanic or something
like that.
But players don't
necessarily assume
that they should be able to walk
outside in space and not die.
So when you choose
your settings,
when you choose your-- when
you choose your storylines,
you have to make
sure that they are
supporting those
kinds of mechanics
that you come in with.
A lot of your games started
off by what mechanic
that you wanted to do.
Make sure that your storylines
are actually supporting that.
Can you think of any games,
commercial games for instance
that you've played, where
the storyline was really
at odds with what the
players were actually
being asked to do.
I see some nods.
Some hands?
Let's call out a few bad ones.
AUDIENCE: Well, one this
is that most-- playing
games, especially
Japanese ones, tend
do have battle systems
that have basically nothing
to do with the story and have
a lot of strange mechanics
that aren't actually related.
For example, the Final
Fantasy games-- your character
can summon these really powerful
monsters, but for some reason
you never actually use
those to solve your problems
in the storyline,
for some reason.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And I would say that's
actually the difference
between the better and the
worse Final Fantasy games.
In the better Final
Fantasy games,
they actually explain
why that doesn't work.
In the worse Final Fantasy
games, you have all this power.
Why aren't you just solving
the problem instantly?
That's a good one.
Any others?
AUDIENCE: Well, I feel like
the classic example is probably
Skyrim, where you're a warrior
fated to this grand destiny
and probably just run around
punching chickens for a while.
PROFESSOR: Well, I'm
trying to remember.
Skyrim, you start off like a
prisoner or something, right?
But I do remember some of
the earlier Elder Scrolls
and a lot of Western RPGs.
It's like, let's go into
the tunnels and kill rats,
because you're the chosen one.
It comes up.
That is actually, I think,
partly fiction against fiction.
It's like, you have the quest
which tells you to kill rats.
And you have the overall
storyline that's telling you
that you're the savior
of the universe.
And that's at odds.
But there are mechanical
issues as well.
Why is your savior
of the universe
picking up all the cheese
wheels in the world,
for instance, which
does happen in Skyrim.
Something else that you can do
is expose more of your system.
How many of you are playing
Destiny right now, by the way?
Just out of curiosity.
A few hands, OK.
One thing that Destiny does
that Halo-- how many of you
have played Halo?
OK, more.
One thing that Destiny
does that Halo doesn't do
is that it actually shows you
how much damage you're putting
up with every single shot.
A little floating number,
in a very RPG-like way,
showing you how effective
your weapon is being.
And that seems to be a necessary
consideration by Bungie,
who made both games, that,
well, even though our games kind
of play in the same way, we need
to reveal this extra little bit
of information, because the
way how weapons work in Destiny
is a little bit less predictable
than how they work in Halo.
So we're actually
just going to show you
how much damage each weapon
does every time you shoot it
by showing you the
numerical amount.
This is a screenshot
from SimCity.
And one of the neat
things about SimCity
is that you can kind of open
the hood on all of the variables
that the game is tracking
at any given times,
and they show you these
lovely little bar graphs.
I think this is, like,
citizen satisfaction or maybe
it's property value.
I'm not sure.
But you can go into all
of these different modes
where you can look at your
city through different lenses
to see all of the
different variables
that the game is tracking
and how they're interacting.
So it takes a lot of
work to be able to reveal
this sort of information.
And if you're not careful, you
can reveal so much information
that a player is just confused
because there's so much data
on the screen at once.
But being clear on this is
the action that you're taking
and this is the result,
or here are all the things
that the game
currently cares about,
is one way to help
people better understand
how your game is working,
so opening up the hood
a little bit.
I don't mean giving
them the source code.
No one's going to read that.
I mean putting things on
screen or through audio
to better reveal what's
happening numerically
in your game.
Previous user experience,
we focus-- yes?
AUDIENCE: What about
the danger of you
revealing that information,
the player seeing how something
works, and then them saying,
I don't like how this works,
I don't want to do this anymore?
PROFESSOR: Then I think you
have a play-testing issue
to consider.
It's not like the player is
confused about the situation.
The question is-- that there
are two possible answers.
One, maybe our game system is
badly tuned or badly designed
in the first place.
And yeah, once people
realize how this game works,
they're not going to
want to play it anymore,
which is a game design issue.
And then the other
situation which
is, well, if we never explained
these numbers to them,
they will actually
better like our game.
Even if they figure out
how this game worked,
by not showing
them these numbers,
they better like this game.
I have that issue with
Destiny, actually.
I don't want to
see those numbers.
And you can make that
decision to hide it.
It's like, this is
complexity that we don't
want players to care about.
You guys have to be
very, very careful,
but that's why design is an
interesting, tough problem.
But those are the
kinds of decisions
you get to make as a designer.
Other questions?
We used this earlier when
we looked at Animal Upon
Animal, Tier auf Tier,
And people immediately
assume that this
was a game for kids
based on user experience,
other kinds of games
that you've seen-- the color
of the font and the shape
and how it's written.
This is an illustration of how
pull-to-refresh works on iOS.
If you want to refresh all of
the email in your mail client,
you pull it down, and
this little circle
starts to stretch, and
there's a little icon there.
And then it starts refreshing.
That is not an interaction
with a computer
that anybody's born with.
This is something that someone
had to learn from somewhere.
Anyone can think of when was
the first time you saw this
on a cellphone?
On Instagram?
OK.
Any other earlier things?
I think Twitter actually
has the patent on this,
but they don't seem to have
sued anyone for using this,
and Apple uses it
now-- pull-to-refresh
for your Twitter feed.
And now it's in
many mobile apps.
And mobile apps just
assume that we don't
have to teach anyone this.
They just assume that if you are
a regular user of mobile apps,
pull-to-refresh is
something that people
will understand how to do.
Here's another example.
This is early in Half-Life 2.
And early in the game,
you're just given a crowbar.
And the dialogue
even says, you know,
assume you know what
to do with this thing.
Why can the game just
give you a crowbar
and not tell you how to use it?
Why can Half-Life 2 do that?
AUDIENCE: Because
people know how
to use a crowbar in real life.
PROFESSOR: OK.
There is some real-life
personal experience
about how to use a crowbar.
Although I would argue that how
to use a crowbar in Half-Life 2
is not actually how you
use it in your life.
In real life, you sort
of lever it, right?
In Half-Life 2, you
kind of do that.
Of course, having
to use it in a game
is using the mouse and keyboard.
Why can the game get away
with not explaining to you
what this object is used for?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
a sequel, so you
could assume that the person
played the first game.
PROFESSOR: The assumption that
they've played Half-Life 1.
It's a game for fans.
It's not that crucial a tool,
although eventually they
start to have puzzles
where you need
to solve it using the
crowbar, but you can usually
solve it using some
other weapon as well.
The crowbar happens
to be an iconic weapon
of the Half-Life series.
And so they just assume, you're
getting into Half-Life 2,
you probably realize
that the crowbar
is a thing in this series.
So again, previous
user experience.
There's cultural cues that
come from outside of games.
Like, this is a shot
from Grand Theft Auto.
And even though
you may never have
driven a car that looks
exactly like that,
you can make certain assumptions
about this kind of car.
What kind of car is that?
It's kind of blurry, but
maybe you can make it out.
Does it go fast, or is
it kind of a clunker?
AUDIENCE: Fast.
PROFESSOR: It's
fast, because it's
kind of a streamlined,
sports car look.
So you know that
you're in a fast car.
Grand Theft Auto is a game.
There's a lot of violence.
If somebody shot at you
while you're in this car,
do you expect to
be taking damage?
Yeah.
There's no windows.
There's no steel frame.
If you wanted to get onto
that bridge back there,
how would you do it?
Just go up the on ramp, right?
I mean, you can kind of see
it, but it actually curves off
and then goes onto the bridge.
But you kind of assume that
players have seen real-life
on ramps and sort of understand
how urban geography works.
In this case, it's
particularly an American city.
And they see a bridge
in the background.
And this thing
that slopes upward,
even though it curves away
from the bridge, people
can assume that it actually
leads to the bridge.
So they're using all
of these cultural cues.
But you can take
that idea too far.
So this is a screenshot from the
Magic Cap PDA user interface.
So this was pre Apple
Newton, I believe.
And this was a user interface
for a personal data assistant.
And there are some things
here that sort of make sense.
What do you think the little
postcard thing in the middle
is supposed to be for?
AUDIENCE: Writing postcards?
PROFESSOR: Hm?
PROFESSOR: Writing postcards?
This is a digital device.
Do you think you're actually
using it to write postcards?
AUDIENCE: Internet postcards.
PROFESSOR: Internet
postcards, OK.
What do you think this thing
in the lower right corner does?
AUDIENCE: Recycle bin.
PROFESSOR: It's a recycle bin.
It's a trash bin.
You've seen it in a lot of
different desktop-- this time
it's a trash truck, I'm
assuming because all
of the other recycle
bin and trash bin things
have been copyrighted
or trademarked by Apple
and Microsoft, respectively.
What does the magic lamp do?
AUDIENCE: Grants wishes.
PROFESSOR: Grants your wishes.
Programs?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Like, apps.
Yeah, OK.
Some other hands?
Some other ideas?
AUDIENCE: Help.
PROFESSOR: You think help?
Yeah, you rub the
genie for help.
So we have three
fairly plausible
entirely different
interpretations
of what that magic lamp is.
This is an indirection metaphor.
Everything on this
desktop-- and we
still use that
terminology today.
This is from the early '90s.
Every single one
of these things is
a metaphor for something else
that you can use on the PDA.
You're not going to
be writing postcards
using a digital device because
that's a medium that exists
outside of digital technology.
But you're going to
be sending emails,
so you're going to use that
postcard icon in the middle
to send messages.
Are you going to be
sending faxes exactly?
That's a fax machine.
First of all, in 2014,
I'm not entirely sure
whether anyone recognizes
a fax machine anymore.
Are you going to be using that
thing to make phone calls,
or are you going to be
sending pictures with it?
The clock is not such a
difficult thing to understand.
So some of these
interaction metaphors work,
and some of them don't.
Again, if you put
story in your game
or even some sort of a fantasy
setting or fictional setting,
that's already establishing
a metaphor for your game.
If your game is
about child grows up
and learns to battle
the evils of the world,
for instance, that
maps on pretty closely
to the mechanics
of a lot of games.
That's why the Zelda
franchise works kind of hand
in hand, the storyline
and the mechanic.
You start off as this
kind of helpless kid,
and then you get
all of these tools
and take on bigger
and bigger challenges.
It's a big metaphor
for growing up.
But you can also confuse, or at
the very least, date your game
by over-relying on metaphors.
So if you, say, have a big stop
sign or something that, well,
that's probably pretty timeless.
But it's going to assume that
everyone has seen a stop sign,
and your users will be
unclear whether that
means stop the current action
or stop forward velocity.
Those are two different things.
So I'm just saying, be careful
of using too many metaphors
to do the heavy lifting on
getting your concepts across.
Often you're going
to have to rely
on multiple means of
feedback to help people
understand how your game works.
Now, one thing that you're
going to be keeping your eye out
for when you're designing for
usability errors-- mistakes
that people are making,
but I want to clarify there
are two different
kinds of errors,
and mistakes are
only one of them.
Slips are skilled
behavior errors.
Someone who knows what they
want to do and accidentally
did the wrong thing.
How many of you
have gone to class
when you had intended to
go to a friend's dorm room,
and you just ended
up in your class?
OK, yeah.
Or driven to work
or something while
intending to drive to
your friend's house?
So it's not like you didn't
know where your friends were.
You knew where
your friends were,
and you knew that
you were going there.
But somewhere along, your skill
behavior of getting to class
just automatically took over.
And you did the wrong thing.
I have calling your boyfriend
by your last boyfriend's
name on my examples here.
That's a tricky one.
But things like
clicking a button that
looks very similar to the
button that you actually
wanted to click.
This is, by the way,
something that you
find in Dark Souls and many,
many different fantasy games,
is you have a
monster that happens
to look like a treasure chest.
And this was intentional.
So the game designer is using
this kind of player error
deliberately to sort of trick
you into a powerless position.
Ooh, a treasure chest.
I'm going to open it.
And it bites you.
So it's going to mimic.
And those are things that might
be OK to leave in your game.
If it happens too often,
it can be frustrating,
especially if you're sort
of designing your user
interface in a way that
leads people to confusion,
and you want to be able to catch
those errors and fix those.
But a little bit harder to
fix are mental model errors,
where somebody actually thinks
your game works differently
from how your game
actually works,
and they're going to make
a mistake because of that.
So how many of you play Portal?
All right.
Up until you meet
this thing, is there
anything in the game that
can actually hurt you?
Oh, yeah.
You can fall into water,
that really, really
icky-looking water.
So that's the
first time you die.
But that's something
that you fall into.
That's something you
kind of like-- yeah,
you can kill yourself, but
you have to kill yourself.
Then you meet these
things, and you
haven't met a single thing
that is out to get you.
And then you walk
around the corner,
and what does this thing do?
AUDIENCE: It gets you.
PROFESSOR: It gets you.
It shoots you.
It's a turret.
It says some really, really
cute things, and then it's like,
are you still there?
Bum-bum-bum-bum-bum.
And then you suddenly
realize in this game
that there are things out
there who are actively
going to be trying to hurt
you even if you're not
moving, for instance.
So now, up until that point
in the game, the player
will be perfectly
legitimately thinking,
the only way that I'm going
to lose or die in this game
is to make a mistake
myself or to deliberately
cause myself to be in a position
that's going to kill me.
But then they find these things,
and they realize, no, actually,
there are hostile
elements in this game that
are out to get me.
And now they have to
revise that understanding
of what this game is all about.
Now, this is the challenge.
You as a designer,
you are the people
who are making the games.
You are making these
systems that players
are going to interact with.
And when players are
playing the game,
they're sort of having a little
conversation with the system.
But your conversation with
the system is kind of one way.
You are making this
system, and then
the system isn't there
to tell you, by the way,
the players are
doing this thing that
clearly indicates that you don't
understand what's going on.
But the system isn't going
to be able to give you
that information.
Actually, if you take our
design class in the spring,
it gets even worse, because
what you're really in control of
are the game mechanics.
And those are going to result in
emergent dynamics-- strategies,
for instance, things
that are optimal,
things that are going to lead
people in a downward spiral.
And that's going to
create an experience
for the player,
the aesthetic which
we will get a little bit
into later in the class.
They're just what the
player actually experiences.
So the player may
think your game
is very threatening
and dangerous
and it's out to get them,
when really to you, it's
just a perfectly harmless
logic puzzle, because this
is what you have control over.
But through all of
that interaction,
what you've got here is kind
of a second or even third order
problem, where the
thing that you get,
where you can actually
create, is not
the thing that the players
are actually experiencing.
So that's why
you've got to test.
That's the only way
that you are actually
going to get information about
what the players are actually
experiencing.
You can't intuit it just
by looking at your design.
Maybe with a lot of
experience, you will eventually
start to get some
best practices,
but you still have to
do usability testing,
even if you're
extremely experienced.
So one way to do testing
is to actually set
goals for the player.
Sometimes when you're doing this
in the middle of play-testing,
the players can come
up with your own goals.
But what I like to do
is actually ask players,
all right, I want you to create
a new game with a new player
and give it a name
of whatever you want.
Give them a specific
goal, and see
how they go about that process
of actually accomplishing that.
And of course, while they're
doing that, you observe them.
You encourage them
to talk aloud.
You observe where they're
moving their mouth,
or if they're doing a
tablet game, observing
where the fingers are looking.
Try to figure out what
they're looking at.
In big companies they
can do things like eye
tracking-- Riot Games talks a
little bit about eye tracking--
to actually figure out
what they're looking at.
But sometimes if
they're talking aloud,
they will say, well, I
see all these buttons.
And they all have icons on them.
And this one looks like
it might mean delete game,
so I'm not going
to click on that.
This one looks
like a disk drive,
so I think it's a save game, so
I'm not going to click on that.
And then while they're
saying all of these things,
you start to understand
how your players actually
understand the things that
you put into your game.
And you can figure out why
they're making these errors.
So you're looking for
them to make these errors,
and you want to record
them down so that later on,
when you go back to design
and go back to implementation,
you can fix them.
Or you can give players
the necessary feedback
to avoid those kinds of errors.
But it's important--
when they make an error,
you have to try to identify what
the player's reaction to that
is.
Say something happens that
they didn't quite expect.
Are they surprised,
or are they confused?
I thought I was
creating a new game,
but I ended up
opening an old game.
That's probably a
confusion situation.
I thought this was going
to take out one enemy,
but it took out five enemies.
Pretty nice surprise--
players might like that.
So even though
it's an error, you
might be able to just live with
that, or even amplify that.
Let's give these
players these weapons
that occasionally do critical
damage and surprise the player
by how bad-ass the players are.
Are they frustrated,
or are they engaged?
I chose Flappy Birds in
particular as an example
here because when people
are playing Flappy Birds,
they get very angry, right?
But then they go back
and play it again.
Are they frustrated?
Well, yes.
But are they engaged?
Yeah, they are.
For some people, Flappy Birds
is an extremely engaging game,
and it's kind of a pity
you can't get it anymore.
I also have two different
versions of Flappy Birds.
One is kind of an
Arduino powered version,
but it's really made out
of paper and cardboard.
And one is the actual digital
version, so to remind you,
you can do this without
having to actually implement
a digital version.
You can do this with
your paper prototype.
You just have to create a paper
prototype of a user interface
instead of just game play.
So you can do testing
even before you've
written a single line of code.
So I've talked a lot
about constraints.
Now, so far everything that
I've been talking about
has been about
informing the player
and then trying to
catch those errors
and then feed that back into
your design of how you provide
more information to the player.
But you can also prevent
certain problems.
Constraints is one way, where
you just make it impossible
for them to do the wrong thing,
or at least early on, when
you had multiple choices,
you sort of take some
of those choices away and
maybe later reintroduce
those choices when
you are fairly sure
that you've understood what
the consequences of those are.
You can do conformation,
which is you take an action,
and then the game asks
you, are you really
sure you want to do that?
However, this is
really sub-optimal.
Any idea why?
Why is it bad to get a little
dialogue box asking you,
are you sure you
want to do this?
AUDIENCE: If you
wanted to get to it,
it might be really annoying.
PROFESSOR: OK.
It gets annoying, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And it might
make you doubt what you
were doing in the first place.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Are you really sure you
want to close this web page?
You really sure that you
want to save this game.
Well, maybe not, but maybe
that was the right thing to do.
You can also get really
automated on that.
Players can sort of learn
to just click yes every time
that thing pops up, and then
kit kind of defeats its purpose.
If all you're doing is
throwing up a dialogue box
and they're going to say every
minute or something like that,
and the answer 90%
percent of the time
is yes, then players start
to learn to just click
yes every time they
see the dialog box,
whether or not they actually
intended to click yes or not.
And that's bad.
You're training them
to sort of defeat
the confirmation process.
And then you get
dialog boxes like this.
I don't know what
the buttons do.
So this is Skype, obviously.
This itself can be so
confusing for players.
The confirmation dialog itself
is a piece of user interface
that can go right
and can go wrong.
So you've just
introduced a new element
that can be misinterpreted
in the design of the game.
So confirmation is something
that exists, is often used,
and can backfire, and we need to
be aware that it can backfire.
You can also do checks.
If you've ever entered a code
into Xbox Live or PlayStation
network or the Apple
App Store, the numbers
that you're typing
into the system
have to fit some sort of
checksum or error correction
protocol.
And you can prevent
certain errors
by doing checks on the
data that you're entering.
Now, this is probably
very familiar for anyone
who's done any kind of user
interface, software engineering
class.
But this is one from
Microsoft Xbox Love.
And if you type
in a code that you
might have gotten from a
giveaway or a free coupon
from a game developer,
or maybe a card
that you bought at
the store, they're
always 25 characters long.
They're always separated by
these dashes in chunks of five.
I don't have to type
those dashes in.
I just start typing, and
those dashes fill themselves
in automatically.
If I do type the dash, the input
box will just ignore the dash,
and it will only allow me to
enter in those characters.
So that makes sure that
the dashes are always
exactly five characters
apart from each other.
And that's a visual
way to provide
a check while I'm entering
this long string of characters.
I can do this sort
of visual check
of, are my characters
appearing in the right position
in the string as they
are printed on my card,
and as it is being
displayed on my screen.
You can do other
kinds of checks--
like, if you try to do the same
thing on the Apple App Store,
I believe it could be
numbers, it could be letters,
or whatever, but you can hit
OK as soon as you enter it in,
and the system actually does
a quick check before it even
sends the code off to Apple
on whether that's actually
a valid string, that fits
a certain kind of checksum
algorithm.
Before it sends it off to Apple.
And if it's a wrong one, it
just tells you right away,
no, you actually made an error.
You can fix that now.
So you don't have to wait
for it to hit the server
and come back.
But say the error does happen.
The player has made
a mistake, and it
happens to be a mistake that
you know about as a designer.
And you know this mistake
is going to come up often.
This kind of error
is going to happen.
And maybe it's a slip,
maybe it's a mistake.
And you want to
provide some feedback.
So first of all, make sure that
you are informing the player
that an error has happened.
And you need to test whether
the information that you're
providing, whether
it's audio or visual,
some combination of the
two, is actually something
that people notice
and see, and then they
realize that, oh, I've
made a mistake somewhere.
And then you've got
to get them some tools
to be able to fix that problem.
There's backwards,
which is basically undo.
This is Words With
Friends, for instance.
If you enter in
some sort of word--
this is an online
game, by the way.
It's a multi-player game
that you play on your phone.
And because it's
Words With Friends,
you're basically playing
Scrabble against somebody
who's geographically
separated from you.
And if you've taken a turn,
you've entered in a word.
And then you say,
wait a minute, I've
come up with a better word.
You can hit Undo.
I think it's called Recall.
The button is actually
called Recall.
Take your move
back and then just
replay your turn
before the other person
has taken their turn.
But that's backwards
error recovery,
very good for things
like turn-based games,
games that you play by
email for instance or games
that you are sort of--
like Final Fantasy Tactics,
or strategy games.
A lot of strategy games
which are turn-based
allow you to sort of
undo your decisions.
Even if you've
said, yes, this is
what I want to
do, wait a minute,
this is not what I want to do.
I want to undo that.
There's also forward
error recovery.
This is a screenshot of
Mario where Mario's mid-jump,
and based on player
experience up to this point,
you realize halfway
through the jump
that you're not going to
be able to make that jump.
What can Mario do?
You can go backwards.
You can change
direction in midair
and say, oop, not
what I'm going to do.
It doesn't rewind time.
You're still moving
time in the game.
And time is important
in a Mario game.
But the player has the tool to
say, I'm going to try to jump.
No, I'm not going to
complete this jump.
I'm going to go backwards
before it's too late.
There is a consequence to that,
and the player is losing time.
And in many of
your games, you're
going to want to allow those
errors to happen but then
give players tools to be able to
take a new action to compensate
for the mistake of
the previous action.
And that is called
forward error recovery.
Now, if it's a mistake that
happens near the end of a game
session-- say you're
making a multi-player game
and somebody's about to win.
Forward error recovery
may not be something
that you want to make too
easy, because somebody's
spent a long time actually
getting themselves
in a position where
they can win the game.
And then the person who's losing
uses whatever forward error
recovery tools you've given
them to say, ah, let me just
take back all of
those mistakes I did
and then come back from behind.
Well, if you were explicitly
designing a game where someone
is supposed to be able
to come back from behind,
like Mario Kart does something
like that, then that's great.
But if you're trying to
make some sort of game
where long-term strategy is
supposed to pay off, then yeah,
you don't want to make
those forward recovery
tools too powerful.
Let people live
with their mistakes.
One last point, and
I save this for last
because I want you to
be thinking about this
in your team, so
something for you
to go into discussion
about after this talk,
is accessibility.
One challenge is that
when people think,
my game is for everyone, my game
is for anybody who plays games,
is that that's not actually
what the game ends up being.
Often it becomes
this, which is you're
going to assume that your
player is focused and has
full use of their hands
and full visual acuity,
that they speak
English so they'll
understand any text
that you give them,
that they know how to
install stuff in a computer
and they've played games
before, that they are around
about your age, that they
have desktop computers that
have lots of processing power,
especially if you're doing a 3D
game, that their mice have more
than one button, that they're
actually using mice
and not a trackpad,
that they've got
headphones so they're
going to listen
to every audio cut
that you're going to give
them without distraction.
So these particular
red line things
are the things that I want
you to be willing to question
about your own game.
There are some things
like-- they're speaking,
computer-literate young adults.
It's great to be able to
design games for people
who are not like you.
It is a little bit beyond the
scope of this particular class,
although you do have to keep in
mind that we are also designing
this games, your
final fourth project,
for people who may be working
for the Red Cross Red Crescent
Climate Centre.
So you want to keep them in
mind and consider-- many of them
actually speak English.
They may be
foreigners, people who
work in other countries, who
will appreciate a game that
is a little bit more language
agnostic or even localized
for them.
Shall we assume that
the computers are
capable of handling your game?
OK, I think for this
class that's all right.
But shall we assume that
the computers are only
running your game and nothing
else, that they're not
running any IM clients--
or a lot of the games
are going to be browser
games so that they
don't have any other browser
windows open, for instance.
I think that might be asking
too much of your player.
You might want to assume that
they have other things running
around in the background-- their
iTunes playlist, for instance--
and which is going to
interfere with your sound.
You should be able to design
your game so that you don't
assume everyone has a left
mouse button and a right mouse
button, or necessarily a mouse.
For one thing, it'll
make testing easier.
A couple of you
discovered last time
you did a visual test, that
if you don't have a mouse,
a lot of your games actually
became difficult to play.
You might want to have
that discussion-- at least
have that discussion with
your team, and if you decide,
no, a mouse is essential,
make it very, very clear
that's what you're saying.
And put it in your game.
Say, this game is best played
with a mouse and headphones.
There's a lot of iOS games out
there that require headphones,
and they will state
right upfront,
this game is best
played with headphones.
And I would like you to at
least consider colorblindness.
Actually, yeah, there we go.
When you are designing
art for your game,
buttons that need
to be distinguished
from each under or
visual cues, consider
that there are people who
can't tell the difference
between certain color pairings.
What are common ones?
Red, green.
Red, blue?
AUDIENCE: Blue, yellow.
PROFESSOR: Oh, blue, yellow.
And red, blue.
Red, blue.
Blue, yellow.
And red, green.
Those are the most common
ones, but there's a lot
of colorblindness out there.
And it affects, I think,
20% of the population.
10?
10 to 20%?
AUDIENCE: I think it's as
much as 10% of the population.
PROFESSOR: 10% of
the population.
So there's a lot
of people out there
who might well want to
be playing your game
but can't because they can't
tell apart those visual cues
that you're giving them.
So make sure that they're also
taking advantage of things
like shape and brightness.
These are things where if
somebody is colorblind,
they can at least
still distinguish shape
from each other.
So instead of having red
diamonds and blue diamonds,
you have red diamonds and
blue stars or something,
and that makes it easier to
tell that there's a difference.
I mentioned other application
windows, touch pads,
or the possibility that somebody
might be playing your game
muted, which means
make sure that not
all of the feedback that you're
giving them is audio only.
Make sure that you're
also giving them
some sort of visual
feedback so that they
understand that if
they're playing in a cafe
or something like
that, they will still
be able to understand that
they're making mistakes,
or errors or slips.
All right.
That went way longer
than expected,
but I did warn you guys
it was going to be long.
Any questions before
we wrap this one up?
OK.
All right.
Well, now is a break
time, I believe?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Take a 10-minute break.
At 2:47, come back here.
If you want to play-test
a paper prototype
or have any kind of testing
in your game, let us know.
Otherwise, working in teams.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
A lot of you have
mentioned how hard
it is to schedule a meeting.
You've got the
rest of this class
to be able to meet
with your team.
And either test something, or
you can just work on your game.
If anyone wants to look at
these books or this game,
come up to the
front, have a look.
Thank you.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]